yo creo que ya estamos listos para ver
el todo el panorama y qué es lo que
preocupa tanto al gobierno ahorita lo
que hice es dibujar la hoja de balance
de un bonche de bancos de forma muy
simplificada y bueno deje que todas las
hojas de balance se vean igual cada uno
de estos cuadrados representa la hoja de
balance de un banco
y el lado izquierdo son los activos a
ver déjame déjame lo remarcó un poco con
color magenta
voy a hacerlo un poco más gordo
pero bueno este cuadrado de aquí en la
izquierda estos son los activos del
banco
y lo que voy a remarcar con azul esos
son los pasivos del banco que le puse
quedan 4 billones sus activos los divide
en 3 billones de otras cosas y 2
billones de ese de dos porque éstos son
el meollo del asunto ok esto es lo que
está detrás de lo que está pasando
entonces tienes un billón de capital
porque son esta es otra forma de ver qué
pasivos más capital es igual a los
activos o que los activos menos los
pasivos es igual al capital ok
y solo lo copia y lo pegue bonche de
veces no sé cuántos de estos cuadros voy
a necesitar pero ya están listos pero
supongamos para hacerlo simple que un
bonche de bancos en el sistema tiene una
hoja de balance idéntica obviamente no
todas sus hojas de balance son idénticas
pero sí podrían tener propiedades
similares
obviamente no siempre es este el caso
algunos bancos tienen mucha exposición a
la luz e de ojos otros tienen muy poca
algunos de ellos evalúan sucede o de una
forma mucho más conservadora que otros
pero para hacer las cosas simples y sé
que todos los bancos tuvieran en su hoja
de balance de dedos con un valor libro
mayor que el valor libro de su capital y
no por nada lo hice así lo hice porque
entonces nos lleva a preguntarnos si
estos bancos sólo tienen un problema de
liquidez o si son insolventes si tú
crees firmemente que estos activos valen
3 billones y estos pasivos 4 entonces es
un problema de liquidez o de insolvencia
dependiendo de si éstos valen 2 billones
ok si valen 2 billones entonces tienes
un billón de capital si valen un billón
y medio entonces pues fueron un poco
optimistas aquí pero aún así tienes
medio billón de capital todavía de
solvente y en esa situación en teoría si
no tienen efectivo cuando se cumple el
plazo de una de sus deudas podrían
salvarse pidiendo un préstamo y después
tal vez vender sus activos pero seguir
con un capital positivo sin embargo si
el verdadero valor de estos dedos y eso
es una pregunta filosófica cuál es el
verdadero valor de las cosas y con
respecto a eso lo mejor que se nos ha
ocurrido a los humanos es el mercado el
valor de mercado suele ser la mejor
representación del verde el verdadero
valor de algo pero si el verdadero valor
de esto es un billón o menos entonces
tenemos problemas por ejemplo si estas
no valen nada entonces tenemos 3
millones de activos menos 4 millones de
pasivos o sea tenemos capital negativo
esta compañía no valen nada y prestarle
dinero a este banco sería como tirar
dinero a la basura alguna de las
personas con las que este banco está en
deuda
no volverá a ver su dinero si es el
prestador con menor preferencia o sea si
se van a la bancarrota y cuando
distribuyen el dinero tú eres la última
persona la que le pagan entonces prestar
tu dinero es tirarlo a la basura pero
ahora quiero que veas todo el panorama
porque si este fuera el problema de un
solo banco no sería gran problema si
sólo fuera bear stearns o lehman
brothers no hay problema tu deja que los
banqueros codiciosos quiebren
seguro estarán bien con todos los bonos
que han reunido después de abastecer
estos dedos por los últimos ocho o cinco
años pero lo que yo quiero enseñarte en
este vídeo es a qué se refieren las
personas cuando hablan de riesgo
sistémico entonces estos cuatro millones
de pasivos fueron préstamos muy
probablemente de otros bancos y entonces
estos préstamos de otros bancos son
activos para los otros bancos
a ver si este es el banco y este es el
banco ve entonces tal vez un millón de
estos son un préstamo del banco ve
y entonces si este es un préstamo del
banco ve el banco de seguro tiene un
activo que dice que le prestó un billón
de pesos al banco y bueno en la hoja de
balance le llaman préstamo al banco y en
uno de estos pasivos es un préstamo del
banco ve ok entonces tomaron este dinero
y se lo dieron al banco a
y tal vez el banco a tomo este dinero y
decidió prestárselo a este banco o sea
vamos a poner un nombre al banco se y
estoy una vez va a ser el banco ve
entonces decidió agarrar este dinero que
ahora forman parte de sus activos
dárselo al banco sé
entonces dentro de la hoja de balance en
la parte de los pasivos del banco se va
a ver una cosa que diga que tomó dinero
prestado al banco y dentro de la hoja de
balance del banco a habrá un activo que
diga que le prestó dinero al banco se
ahora dentro de la hoja de balance del
banco a también hay otra cosa de la
parte del lado de los pasivos que dice
que tomó ese dinero prestado el banco ve
y bueno podríamos seguir haciendo esto
con todos estos otros bancos y ver cómo
se enreda todo no o de una vez ya cerra
el círculo ok el banco ve digamos que él
le debe dinero a alguien porque todo le
deben dinero a alguien aquí tiene 4
billones de pasivos se los tiene que ver
a alguien entonces digamos que tomo este
dinero prestado del banco sé
entonces el banco se
le prestó dinero al banco ve entonces
aquí está el algo que dice que le prestó
dinero al banco ve y aquí hay algo que
dice que tomó dinero prestado del banco
sé
entonces si estamos ya en una situación
muy enredada e interesante digamos que
ahora se vence este préstamo ok el
préstamo del banco ve al banco a ya
hemos estudiado esto varias veces y
digamos que por alguna razón todos estos
préstamos que hizo el banco a otros
bancos no son líquidos todavía no se
cumple su plazo o sea que el banco no
puede cobrar los entonces pues se venció
este plazo se venció este préstamo y no
puede vender ninguno de estos activos y
el banco a fuerza tiene que conseguir un
millón de pesos para pagarle al banco ve
esta es la situación no puede vender
ninguno de estos activos y por lo tanto
todo recae en los deseos y pues como ya
sabemos hay unos cuantos problemas por
aquí tal vez crees que esto es sólo un
problema de liquidez que estos dos
billones de activos realmente valen dos
billones pero el banco a simplemente no
puede venderlos porque no hay nadie que
quiera comprarlos
aunque pues yo diría que si no hay nadie
que quiera comprarlos entonces sube
valores 0 pero digamos que el banco dice
que solo tiene un problema de liquidez
que estos realmente valen 2 billones
algo que podrían hacer es conseguir otro
préstamo tal vez el gobierno esté
dispuesto a aceptar éstos como garantía
el gobierno les daría tal vez un billón
y entonces podrían usar este dinero para
pagarle al banco ve el préstamo pero
digamos que está nuestra opción porque
estos dos son tan problemáticos que
inice que el gobierno está dispuesto a
aceptarlos como garantía incluso ahora
que el gobierno está dispuesto a hacer
casi cualquier cosa para apoyar al
mercado la otra opción es que consigan
una infusión de capital que un fondo
soberano les inyecte efectivo diluyendo
las acciones tal vez tenían quinientos
mil millones de acciones y ahora tendrán
dos billones de acciones y así el fondo
soberano adquirirá aproximadamente el 75
por ciento de la compañía pero a cambio
de ese 75 por ciento pagará tal vez 2
billones y así ya podrán pagar este
préstamo y tendrán un poco más de dinero
pero digamos que tampoco tenemos esa
opción porque los fondos soberanos
también se han quemado mucho últimamente
entonces qué sucede
pues ya hemos visto qué sucede si no
puedes obtener un nuevo préstamo que
reemplace a este y no puedes obtener una
infusión de capital de parte de un fondo
soberano te vas a la bancarrota y eso es
justo lo que les pasó al limón brothers
lehman brothers quebró ningún fondo
soberano ni nadie más compró la compañía
ni les dio un préstamo y bueno tal vez
debería hacer otro vídeo con este
escenario de hecho debería llamarle a
este el banco l pero pues no quiero
ofender a nadie le voy a seguir llamando
banco a yo no considero que lehman
brothers hayan sido los peores ni
tampoco los mejores jugadores o sea en
realidad eran igualitos a todos estos ok
pero cuando caen en la bancarrota algo
muy interesante pasa o sea por ejemplo
el banco ve y estaba muy preocupado por
estos dedos
y seguramente estaba pensando algo así
como uy cuando se acabe el plazo del
préstamo que me dio el banco se puede
estar en graves aprietos o cuando se
venza cualquiera de estos otros
préstamos porque voy a estar justo en
esta situación voy a estar en la misma
situación a la que estoy forzando al
banco a estar pero además ahora tengo un
nuevo problema porque lo más probable es
que no vayan a pagar este préstamo ok el
banco a se está yendo a la bancarrota y
pues tal vez ahí nos vamos a dar cuenta
que estos no valen pero absolutamente
nada y si no leen nada pues no sé tal
vez yo tengo muy poca preferencia dentro
de todos los deudores dea y bueno todos
todas las personas a las que les debe
dinero y tal vez no paguen nada o si me
pagan
tal vez me van a pagar unos cuantos
centavos por cada peso que yo les preste
entonces este préstamo que yo creía que
valía un billón de pesos porque eso es
lo que pague por él ahora tengo que
reevaluar lo
y escribir que esté activo vale tal vez
punto 5 billones de pesos en lugar de un
billón y entonces ahora tengo estos dos
problemas que ahí tengo este problema y
este problema y pues este préstamo
además no es líquido el banco está en la
bancarrota y para que me paguen con que
esperar a que liquiden todos estos
activos y después tengo que vender los
activos con los cuales me pagaron
entonces en realidad este es un activo
congelado así es que estoy atorado con
estos activos no líquidos y además al
menos este el préstamo del banco no vale
lo que yo creía que valía y pues estos
la verdad uno nunca sabe cuánto valen
pero bueno tengo estos dedos y tal vez
ojalá no sea el caso pero tal vez otros
estos activos es un préstamo al banco de
este banco
y pues quién sabe pero igual y este
banco también cae en la bancarrota y
entonces tengo otro préstamo otro activo
echado a perder encima de estos dedos
pero pues la verdad la verdad es que
estos cds son el meollo del asunto
ok ellos fueron los que provocaron esta
situación si el banco hubiera podido
vender estos dedos por 2 millones de
pesos no hubiera provocado toda esta
reacción en cadena
y la caída de lehman brothers fue lo que
catalizó toda esta cadena de sucesos y
pues te puedes imaginar que ahora el
banco se está muy preocupado porque el
banco ve tiene todos estos activos
congelados encima de estos tebeos y se
está empezando a ver muy mal y
obviamente ahora es todavía menos
probable que cuando un banco digamos el
banco de bajada caiga en una situación
peligrosa es mucho menos probable que
pueda conseguir un préstamo de algún
otro banco porque ahora todos los bancos
están asustadísimos y están diciendo
algo así como yo no lo va a prestar mi
dinero a nadie si lleva a conseguir
efectivo simplemente me voy a quedar con
él para que cuando sea mi turno cuando
el mercado me voltea a ver a mí al menos
tenga yo un poco de efectivo en mis
activos así es que todos están
congelados
todo el mundo quiere cobrar los
préstamos que le digo a los demás y
nadie quiere dar nuevos préstamos esta
es la situación en la que estamos y ese
es el problema que el gobierno está
tratando de aplacar pero bueno
confrontar este problema en el próximo
vídeo
ya se nos acabó el tiempo